hey this is Mel strong and in this
lecture we're going to be talking about
renewable energy
so the first source of renewable energy
we're going to talk about is the Sun and
so we're going to talk about how we
might be able to use the Sun to generate
electricity or how to harness the Sun
for other things so in the previous
lecture we talked about how electricity
is generated and we talked about the
steam turbine and we said that there is
this apparatus that's got a bunch of
looks like fan blades and steam comes in
and pushes these blades and this entire
thing spins and as it spins it turns a
magnetic field in circles and that's
next to a conductor generates
electricity and so last time we talked
about well what would make steam and and
around most of the world the way this is
done is we burn fossil fuels that
generates heat that boils water that
makes steam so could we use the Sun to
make steam and this is one thing that
could be done is if you can imagine if
you could concentrate the heat of the
Sun to boil water then you could use a
steam turbine in the in the entire
apparatus that we talked about before
for generating electricity except
instead of burning coal we can use this
Sun so here we've got a bunch of
parabolic mirrors and in the center of
the mirror the other is a glass tube and
the Sun is being reflected to the center
of these tubes and inside the tube is a
fluid that gets heated to way beyond the
boiling point of water and then it gets
piped over to this in the background
there's a steam turbine over here and
just like in the coal-fired power plant
the boils water makes steam towards a
turbine turns magnets and generates
electricity
now the flue that they use a lot of
times is salt not salt water just
actually pure salt
and if you heat up salt thousands of
degrees it will melt and act like a
fluid and so that's what they actually
use for most of these is their salt
that's so hot it's molten and it flows
in these glass tubes and again you can
see there's the the generator in the
background there so here is a an
installation and and by the way this is
called concentrated solar power that's
the term that's used for this kind of
technology so you have rows and rows of
these parabolic reflectors with a little
glass tube in the center with melting
salt and all of this is sent over to the
power plant that's over here now one of
the advantages of using this
concentrated solar power is that that
salt gets so hot that it actually stays
hot overnight and it will continue to
generate steam overnight so this is a
solar power technology that generates
electricity in the dark because it gets
so hot during the day and it retains as
heat throughout the night here's another
version of it Sandia Labs is actually
working been working on this these are
mirrors and they all reflect the Sun to
this capsule and this capsule is
something called a Stirling engine it's
a heat powered engine and so as one side
of this is hot and the other side is
cooler it that temperature difference
will will cause this little engine to
run and they can generate electricity
that way here's another version of that
there's a parabolic mirror and again one
of those Stirling engines that's a
generating electricity on the end here
here's an installation and I think this
is in Australia where they have several
of these dishes and you can kind of get
a sense there this one is glowing you
know it's pretty hot on one side there
as is this one and and apparently these
these dishes so they track the Sun so
they're always reflecting the Sun to
this Stirling engine that's enough to
generate generates enough electricity
for a small town and this is not a new
idea so here's one from 1901 this is a
solar-powered steam engine
and so it's the same idea that you've
got parabolic mirrors that are blowing
water here that makes steam and turns a
probably a piston on this one instead of
a turbine but this is a solar-powered
steam engines this is an old idea but
this is very expensive to make and coal
is super cheap so these really didn't
catch on because why would you go
through the expense of building all this
because you're gonna shovel coal for
next to nothing and you don't need to
deal with all that so these really never
caught on another version of this is
sometimes called the Tower of Power and
there's these are all mirrors down here
and the mirrors are on a tracking system
so they're tracking the Sun and they're
always reflecting the Sun so that it
lands on this capsule up here which is
at the top of this tower and inside that
capsule is molten salt so it works just
like the ones I've been talking about
the first ones with the parabolic
mirrors with molten salt it's just that
this version the mirrors are moving and
reflecting the Sun to this one spot
here's one that's in Nevada
that's just recently come on the line
and it gets so hot that this the top of
this tower glows pretty brightly like
you can't even look at it and there
there's been some complaints actually of
pilots that are flying in the area that
say it's too bright to look at now there
another one again you can see the the
capsule appear glowing in all these
mirrors tracking the Sun reflecting it
onto that one spot and again the big
advantage here is that you can use steam
turbine technology CDs so that's all the
same from coal-fired power plants and it
gets so hot during the day it'll
continue to generate electricity during
the night
here's one from above so you can see all
these mirrors it's kind of like they're
all worshiping their leader that's in
the center here or this one a lot of
these pictures are from Europe these are
more popular in Europe than they are in
the United States because they're very
expensive too
so mostly only the countries that don't
have a lot of fossil fuels have been
investing in this we only have a couple
of them so far so here's two of them and
there's one tower there one tower there
so inside this system we're not going to
go too deep here but here's the mirrors
here's that capsule that gets white-hot
and inside there is molten salt and the
molten salt goes through kind of a loop
or exchanges heat with the water so this
part is what's boiling the water with
that molten salt and then it goes into
this turbine that's what this is so the
fan blades and and then that turns the
generator that's this part and then that
generates the electricity and then
there's a cooling system for the turbine
and that's what this part is but okay
now there's another way that we can
harness the heat of the Sun to help save
electricity and one is you could have a
couple panels on your roof that help
heat water so usually what happens is so
every house has a water heater it might
be gas might be electric and normally
cold water from the ground goes into the
tank so here here's the tank and then
you've got electricity or natural gas
that heats that water up to you know 140
degrees or whatever it is so what a
water a preheater for your water heater
does is the cold water coming from the
ground moves through these boxes and in
these boxes are just some pipes that are
sitting in the Sun and it pre heats the
water before it goes into the water
heater so if the ground water is say 40
degrees and so normally without without
this system you'd have 40 degree water
going into your water heater and having
to warm that up from 40 to 140 let's say
you might run it through these pre
heaters these solar pre heaters and it
might warm it from 40 maybe to 80 or 90
so then you've got 90 degree water going
in and you have to warm 90 degree water
to 140 which doesn't take you
as much energy so this is what these
look like
so again inside they're just some pipes
so they're pretty simple there's no
really any moving parts no electricity
it's just using heat from the Sun
another thing that people can do is they
can use the Sun to actually heat the air
and so Sun hits this collector and
inside this box gets very warm and
there's a system that vents the warm air
into the house so here's an example or
there's one that put it on your roof
it's pretty simple there's just a fan
that blows air from inside the house
into this glass box and then that warms
up and then and then the fan pushes it
out and it just sits there all day and
helps heat your house and other version
okay so everything we've talked about so
far is using the heat of the Sun to
either generate electricity or help save
electricity but the big technology that
everybody has been using especially in
this country to generate electricity is
that a photovoltaic cells a photovoltaic
cell means you use the Sun the photo to
generate electricity volts photovoltaic
now how these work is pretty complicated
we're not going to get into it but it
uses semiconductors there's three layers
of semiconductors which is mostly
silicon except doped with a tiny amount
of something else okay and we're not
going to get into it except to say that
when you have sandwiched layers of
silicon doped with other materials and
the light hits it electrons will be
pushed from one side and tried to get to
the other side so before we took a
magnet and we moved it next to a
conductor and that made the electrons
move here what's happening is with these
three layers of semiconductors mostly
silicon hit with photons of light
electrons will try to move through this
circuit that's all we really need to
know here so it's kind of similar to an
LED light so you think back
last lecture we talked about LEDs light
emitting diodes and we use them as light
and they were these these little square
wafers that when you put a voltage on
them it makes a light it's the same kind
of process but in Reverse you hit it
with a light turns into a voltage so
each little solar cell might be that you
put in your hand for the most part and
they're not very powerful so you put
that thing in the Sun you'll make a very
small but measurable non electricity but
you can't really power anything
important with it you could not power a
house with this for example you might be
able to power like a little tiny light
or something so what we do is we wire a
whole bunch of these solar cells
together and there's different
terminology but these if you put a whole
bunch of these together into this calls
it a module or you might call it a panel
and you know take a bunch of these
modules together to make an array and
the word these words are kind of fuzzy
because this might be called a module or
panel this thing here might be called a
module or an array and then if you wire
a bunch of these together that's also
sometimes called an array not too
worried about the terminology but here's
a whole bunch of them together so each
one of these little squares is a solar
cell and then each one of these might be
called a module or a panel and then all
together all of these together usually
call on the Ray or sometimes a solar
farm so all the solar cells in this in
this diagram are all working together to
generate electricity enough to actually
do something useful so as I can armie a
Smurf's like one a little Smurf doesn't
do anything but you get like a million
of them and they can do something that's
kind of what they're doing with solar
here's another example right so you know
there's hundreds of thousands of
individual solar cells all working in
unison to try to generate electricity
now sometimes they are on trackers
that's the most efficient way so what
that means is they're following the Sun
so they're always getting the maximum
sunlight trackers are very expensive
okay so these ones I showed you in the
past they don't have any tracking system
they're just pointed in one direction
generally you just point them towards
the south part of the sky these are on
trackers as are these so they will move
throughout the day and that gives you
the most energy but again it's the most
expensive well at U and M on the main
campus we actually have a couple of
arrays so if you park on campus there's
the Yale parking structure so right here
that's Lomas and the hospital is kind of
off the it's up in the corner off the
diagram here but on the top of the Yale
parking structure are a series of solar
panels it's rated at the 180 kilowatt
180,000 Watts okay so that's how much
power is being generated when the Sun is
directly shining on it this is what it
looks like up close and you can actually
park your car underneath these solar
panels also on the science and math
learning center building there is
another array that's not quite as big
but here's what that looks like I'm just
using Google Earth to look down on these
you can also get you can put a solar
array on your house so a lot of you know
if your house is oriented in the right
direction like if this is a south-facing
roof then that's a convenient spot to
put solar panels or like these so it
used to be that solar panels were so
expensive that you rarely ever saw a
house with that with with solar panels
with photovoltaic cells now they've been
getting cheaper and cheaper and cheaper
too now you're starting to see this more
and more as a more and more common thing
so let's say you wanted to convert your
house to solar there's a couple
different ways to do it the easy way to
do it is let's say you live in a city
like Albuquerque and you're connected to
what we call the grid so normal
electricity right so the easiest way to
do this is you invest in solar panels
and you invest in
thing called an inverter and what the
inverter does is it converts the
electricity from the solar panels to
something that the electric company
could actually use and so if you live in
certain cities in Albuquerque's one of
them our local power company in this
case PNM is required to buy that
electricity from you during the day so
you got solar panels on your roof but
you're not home and you're not using an
electricity you can sell it to the
electric company during the day and they
pay you per kilowatt hour now Sun Goes
Down your home you need electricity your
solar panels are not working during the
night you buy electricity back from the
power company so the idea here is you
sell it to rent you sell it to them
during the day you buy it from them
during the night and hopefully you
either break even or if you have a lot
of solar panels you might even make a
little money doing this so people that
have a lot of solar panels on the roof
are actually generating a little income
each month if they're selling more than
they're using so this is what the yell
parking structure at UNM does they
during the day they're generating
electricity they're selling it to PNM
then at night the whole parking
structure is lit up and they have to buy
electricity back from PNM and they hope
that they break even now if you're not
connected to the grid let's say you want
a solar power house out in the boonies
or you live in a town where the electric
company will not buy your electricity
gets a lot more complicated because what
are you gonna do at night and what you
have to do is you have to have a big
bank of batteries and if you use the
amount of electricity that most
Americans do you really need a lot of
batteries to store that much electricity
so during the day your solar cells your
solar panels would be charging a
enormous Bank of batteries like what's
shown in this picture and then at night
you are using the electricity from those
batteries now how this would work is
your solar panels go to something called
a charge controller which charged the
batteries right so during the day is
charging the batteries then at night the
batteries
go to something called an inverter which
takes the voltage of the batteries and
converts it to something that your
standard 110 volt thing can could use
that's what an inverter does and that
powers the house one of this advantages
of doing this is well what happens if
you get say a cloudy day or two cloudy
days in a row or you think about those
mid-latitude cyclones if you live in
that part of the country you might have
five cloudy days in a row you're in
trouble because you don't have any way
generating electricity during the day so
a lot of people that live this way also
have like a backup generator or maybe
some wind turbines to help out one thing
that a lot of people don't realize is
that solar cells are not entirely green
and so they work very similar to
computer chips there are silicon wafers
as we talked about that's a very messy
process it takes a lot of chemicals that
generates a lot of waste uses a lot of
electricity so a lot of our solar cells
or solar panels are coming from China
and China doesn't have the pollution
controls that we do and we've talked
about how terrible the air quality in
China is a lot of that at least a
portion of it is coming from the
manufacture of solar panels so it's not
entirely green it takes a lot of energy
to make them and that makes a lot of
pollution once you have them yeah they
will continue making clean energy as
long as they still are around but the
manufacturing process is pretty dirty so
if we look at a map of well so this one
says photovoltaics all the solar
resources of the United States where
would you go to generate the most solar
electricity and probably not surprising
but we New Mexico and Arizona Southern
California have the most hours of
sunlight per year now you can actually
see the pattern here that is the effect
of the Pacific subtropical high again
right so remember we've got that sinking
air from the Hadley cell keeps it very
dry in this part of the country
therefore we have many hours of
available sunlight so almost all in New
Mexico's Cape
generating at least six kilowatt hours
per square meter per day right so if you
had enough solar panels out there you
could generate six kilowatt hours for
every square meter so pros and cons then
once you have the solar panel made 100%
free of greenhouse gases right doesn't
make any noise doesn't produce any air
pollution cons they've been very
expensive to make but in recent years
they've become much much cheaper
photovoltaic cells only work during the
day so storage is a problem unless
you're connected to the grid of course
if you're using the molten-salt you know
that concentrated solar power those
things I can work all night because they
you just get so hot can be used in all
parts of the world right if you live up
in the middle of Canada in the winter
good luck you're not going to have any
sunlight the manufacturing processes
manufacturing process is messy and
consumes energy so it's not completely
free of carbon right so so without
turning things political you can't avoid
some of the politics that have been
going on about solar so our current
administration the Trump administration
has been very anti solar for the most
part so for example our current EPA
chief Scott Pruett as soon as he got in
office he said he's going to get rid of
the solar tax credits which are designed
to help homeowners get solar panels on
their roof there was a tax bill that was
passed end of 2017 that got rid of a lot
of the tax credits for solar and also
also when energy and then earlier this
year Trump put some tariffs on imported
solar panels so the back story here is
that China has been cranking out lots
and lots of solar panels and they've
been able to produce them cheaper than
the American companies have been able to
make them so the
system that we have that's been in place
for the last five to ten years that
China has been making the solar panels
then American companies buy them and
install them in the u.s. so Trump
decided that he was going to put tariffs
on the Chinese solar panels so that
American companies might be able to
compete in in making them which sounds
like a good idea except what that ends
up meaning is that they're so expensive
that that nobody here is really buying
them to put on their houses anymore
so the actual solar industry is taking a
big hit because these tariffs and we
just don't have the manufacturing
capacity at the moment now maybe we'll
build it in the future but right now
this is this has taken a big chunk out
of the solar power industry in this
country there's a whole history of solar
panels in the White House so back in
late 70s Jimmy Carter that guy was our
president and he decided that he would
have solar panels installed on the White
House okay so that he was kind of this
progressive alternative energy kind of
guy so then a few years later we have
Ronald Reagan who was very anti
alternative energy
he had them taken down and then fast
forward a couple administrations and
Obama comes along and puts them back up
except there they're different the solar
panels at Jimmy Carter had were for
heating water Obama solar panels were
for generating electricity then Trump
gets in the office and says he wants to
take the solar panels back down again
but as of right now he hasn't done that
yet so that's the kind of ridiculous
thing we're into that it's turned into
the stupid political argument where if
you're a Democrat you're Pro solar if
you're Republican you're anti solar and
it's just dumb the whole thing is just
dumb okay so there are some calculations
that we can do with solar so let's say
I've got some solar panels on my roof
let's say I just have eight panels and
each one is rated at a hundred watts so
when you buy a solar panel they're rated
in their power in wattage and let's say
that the way that my house is situated I
get
say 12 hours of sunlight a day and we'll
just for simplicity we'll just say let's
imagine it's 12 hours all throughout the
year okay so and we're going to assume
that we're in direct sunlight so that
each one of these is getting the full
hundred watts so my question might be
say how much energy do I generate in a
year okay so that's the question how
much energy do I generate in a year and
where we're headed for this is let's say
in if you know the assumption here is
I'm using that energy instead of burning
coal to generate that electricity how
much coal do I save how much co2 do I
save okay that's where we're headed so
let's do what's calculate energy and
we're gonna use the same formula that we
did before energy is power times time
okay so we don't know this this is what
we're solving for and let's see what's
the power well each one is a hundred
watts but we've got eight of them and
the time is 12 hours a day times 365
days a year okay so this is gonna be our
calculation so I have a hundred times
eight times 12 times 365 so I get three
million five hundred and four thousand
watts times hours watt hours right we're
going to convert this a kWh so I'm gonna
divide by a thousand and that gets me
3504 kilowatt hours so that's how much
energy I have generated on my roof with
my solar panels okay so this is what
I've generated
okay so a question could be well how
much coal did I save from burning how
much coal did I not have to burn right
so remember it's and we'll do in pounds
so coal saved is this if I if this is a
question and we had we had the gin we
had to burn coal to do this we would
multiply this by 2.2 so it's the same
kind of question so 3504 kilowatt hours
and it takes 2.2 pounds for every
kilowatt hour so that gives me something
to divide by a thousand times 2.2 77090
of coal saved okay so I say I prevent
from you know that simple eight panel
array on my roof prevents 7800 pounds of
coal from being burned each year how
much co2 do I prevent from emitting into
the atmosphere I would go back to my
3500 for let's say I asked this in
liters liters of co2 saved prevented
from going into the atmosphere 3504
kilowatt hours and it's a thousand
liters of co2 for every one kilowatt
hour that I burned so I get the number
three million five hundred four thousand
liters of co2 that are saved or
prevented from going into the atmosphere
okay so we can do calculations like this
is the same math that we've seen before
okay we'll do another version of this
type of problem now let's say I've
got a big solar array on the roof say at
UNM and it's rated at 35 kilowatts and
let's say the building is situated so it
gets 10 hours of sunlight a day and I
want to know let's say in a month in 30
days how much coal does this save from
being burned right so how much coal do
we save with this solar array so energy
is power times time again now here's
this case so we had to deal with this in
the aluminum problem sometimes it's best
to get rid of the K in work out the
problem and then convert to kilowatt
hours at the end so here's what I mean
by that K means a thousand right so 35
kilowatts is the same thing as
thirty-five thousand watts times 10
hours times 30 days so I'm going to do
that math and I have 35 thousand times
10 times 30 let's see here so I get
ten million five hundred thousand watt
hours generated in a month and now what
I'm gonna do is divide by a thousand to
turn it into kilowatt hours which gives
me ten thousand five hundred kilowatt
hours kWh in a month so with that I can
then figure out okay well how much cold
would I need multiply that by two point
two so I take ten thousand five hundred
times two point two and I get twenty
three thousand one hundred pounds of
coal in a month that I saved from this
solar array so as the same math as
before the only tricky part with some
people is not knowing what to do with
the K if I when the Razr
is reported as K no kilowatts my
recommendation is replace K with
multiply this by thousand which is what
I did here and then do the math and then
when you get to watt hours divide by a
thousand to turn it into kWh not the
only way to do it
so if you you feel math competent you
know what's going on do it your own way
but this is kind of a foolproof way of
working through it each time so the
other source of renewable energy is that
of wind power
so when turbines are these big wind
mills that as they spin they turn
magnets near conductor at the generate
electricity in a similar way that a
steam turbine works so if you kind of
look inside there's this big white box
that sits behind the blades and inside
there there's a device that takes the
very slow spinning of the blades and
makes it spin faster gears it up so that
you can spin magnets near a conductor
pretty quickly and generate
tricity the blades themselves they can
turn that they can change the pitch so
if it's a little bit of wind there'll be
a certain position if there's a lot of
wind there'll be a different position
but they're always trying to turn is
about the same speed no matter what the
wind conditions are so inside of one
this is kind of what it looks like going
up the tower and here we are in the box
behind those blades so this is the
device that gears takes the very slow
rotation and gears it up so it's
spinning pretty quickly and then
electricity comes out the other end here
or the generator is so windmills are
great when turbines are great because
they they do as long as they're running
they generate no greenhouse gases and in
a lot of places if it's windy it might
be windy every day you're getting
electricity every day but there is a
public backlash against wind turbines
that just like there's been a public
backlash against solar so here are some
of the big issues
some people think they're just ugly and
they ruin the landscape okay though
people don't like to look at them there
have been complaints especially in the
past that they're noisy people live near
them say they you know they can't sleep
they hear them all the time and also
they used to kill birds so the early
designs spun really fast and the birds
would not see the blades and they'd run
right into it and die so these problems
have for the most part been addressed so
talking about sound first you know
California was one of the first states
to really adopt wind technology and they
did a lot of experimentation in
California with different windmill
designs and it's true the first ones
were really noisy they spun really fast
they made a lot of noise so they
experimented with some different designs
here's a two blade design here's a one
blade design which looks kind of funny
it's got a counterweight on the other
side so it doesn't shake itself apart
remember they were experimenting trying
to make the quietest windmill that they
could here's what we call the eggbeater
design it spins vertically around an
axis this way
here's smaller version
these vertical axis wind turbines and
through trial and error eventually they
settled on a design of three blades and
they've managed over time to build these
larger and larger which means that the
blades can actually spend slower and if
you have a blade that's spinning slower
it doesn't make as much noise and the
birds see it and they don't die so this
three by two design is what all the wind
wind turbines now are designed after you
also notice they have a really small
footprint there's a tower down here and
so a lot of places where farmers have a
lot of land
they'll we sell their land to a to a
wind farm and they'll continue to farm
down here it doesn't really bother them
so here's a size comparison looking at
wind turbines since the early 80s off
you can read this but this one says 1981
and at that time a big wind Mill Mariah
tea would produce 55 kilowatts or 55,000
watts
then by the late 80s we are seeing them
up to two hundred thousand watts or two
hundred kilowatts and they're getting
taller by the year 2000 we're looking at
eight hundred and fifty thousand watts
or any 150 kilowatts about 2002 or at
three thousand thousand watts which
means three million watts or three
megawatts right and and so as they make
them bigger you know one of the
advantages of having a very tall
windmill is that the wind is faster up
above our heads and it is at the surface
so they they're in stronger wind and you
have longer blades they catch more of
the wind and they can spin slower and
still produce a lot of power here's
another image of the size comparison a
10 kilowatt windmill versus up to a
three megawatt windmill the difference
in the sizes and they are still planning
on just making them bigger and bigger so
by 2020 this publication is predicting
we'll have a 10 megawatt 10 milli
what wind turbine by then so the
Telegraph in in England they did a
little documentary docu documenting how
noisy windmills were so what they're
doing is they're going up to the
quietest place they could find and they
have a loudness meter a decibel meter
and they're recording how many decibels
of sound is in this location and then
they go to a quiet neighborhood and
again they take measurements in decibels
there okay notice how slow these are
spinning okay that's about how fast
these windmills spin so half mile way
they still can't hear it 200 yards away
they notice that they're still quieter
than the planes flying overhead and they
don't really hear it till they get right
up next to it a few feet away you might
be able to hear it and they notice that
you know an average road is way noisier
than the then the wind turbines so point
being
they're quiet now and noise really is no
longer an issue like it used to be
however there's still people that hate
windmills president Trump famously hates
hates them because according to him
they're ugly he has complained that and
some of his golf courses that you can
see these windmills in the distance and
he doesn't like that so one of the
things that companies are doing is
putting windmills offshore so just a
little bit out in the ocean and out
there nobody can see them nobody can
hear them and also the winds are much
stronger and more consistent off the
coast so out there they can put in some
really big wind turbines you know these
are the biggest ones that that we're
currently making all these in these
pictures are at least 3 million watts
apiece
we watch a little video that's
promotional video from a company that
actually puts these things together and
they're basically bragging about
themselves but he has a video of their
offshore windfarm in 2015 mhm i Vestas
offshore wind celebrated a track record
of 20 years of experience in the
offshore wind industry through our
history we have installed more than 700
offshore turbines equaling more than 2
gigawatts of capacity spread over 17
wind power plants in six European
markets
that's enough wind power to provide
energy for around 1.9 million households
for every turbine installed and
commissioned it has added to the unique
bank of knowledge we now possess
perfected over time and our drive for
innovation has led us to become one of
the industry leaders with the V 112 3.45
megawatt supplying energy to over 3,100
households in 2016
MHI Vestas will install the first V 160
for 8 megawatt turbines offshore the V
164 is the most powerful wind turbine in
the world with a total energy output to
supply more than 7,500 households the
blades reach 80 metres long equivalent
to nine London double-decker buses for
Airbus a380s could fit within the swept
area of over 21,000 square meters so not
all wind turbines are gigantic like
those that you just saw I homeowner can
buy a small one especially if you are on
solar you can buy them that will help
complement your solar installation these
would be a few hundred watts of peace
they do not move slow they move very
fast and they're usually pretty noisy as
well so the United States is a pretty
good place for wind turbines actually
and the windiest part of the country is
kind of right here in the middle now
over the tops of most mountains is a
good place for for installing a wind
turbine so all these places that you see
are kind of this beige color in here our
places where people have installed wind
turbines as wind goes up over a mountain
but right in the middle of the country
there's a root band a really strong wind
that's very reliable and so if you've
ever been safe you need a you know
panhandle of Texas there's that I mean
there's windmills being installed all
over the place it's kind of amazing to
see right now but right kind of in the
middle of the country is is the best
place to install windmill so we have a
lot of wind in this country that we
could harness so pros and cons of wind a
windmill it takes resources to build it
but once it's built as long as it's
running no greenhouse gasses at all you
can get millions of watts
out of a single windmill cons they are
traditionally have been pretty expensive
but that's been coming down and cost
still a public backlash against it some
people just don't like the the looks of
them or whatever also if you have when
installing windmills on top of the ridge
somewhere you know you got to run power
cables up there and that can be quite
expensive to just to install these
things and of course you can't have
windmills everywhere because it's just
not windy everywhere so another source
of renewable energy is that of
geothermal energy idea being if you
drill down on the earth it's going to
get hot and if you live in the right
spot it might get hot enough right under
where you live that you can use that for
hot water and if it's hot enough it
might actually generate steam and you
could turn a steam turbine so what are
the conditions where you might get that
well one is if you live somewhere where
there's recent volcanic activity if
you've had recent volcanic activity
there's probably a blob of magma that's
still down in the crust somewhere might
be a few miles down
but cold groundwater comes close to that
magma body heats up and Rises back to
the surface as hot water if it makes it
all the way to the surface you might get
a hot spring something like this and if
the conditions are right you might get
like a geyser something like Old
Faithful something like that but this is
a essentially a free source of hot water
if you could figure out how to tap it so
in some places like Iceland there is so
much volcanic activity and there's so
much magma in the crust that they have
an endless supply of hot water and so in
Iceland they actually have enough hot
water hot above the boiling point that
they can tap into that and just take
that steam and turn a steam turbine so
this is what a power plant in Iceland
looks like so there's no coal there's no
natural gas it's a it's a pretty simple
looking thing they just take hot water
out of the ground run that through a
turbine generate electricity it's a
pretty neat deal here's another one
right so again all these pipes is
they're bringing in the steam from
underground and turning turbines
Indonesia is another place so Indonesia
is a bunch of islands and they're all
volcanoes and so there's a decent amount
of magma still under the ground they're
generating hot water and so they have
you know here's a big geothermal power
plant same ideas Iceland taking steam
and generating electricity now there's
another way that you can make hot water
underground and that is if you had
friction from faulting so here's a
picture showing you know sometimes the
Earth's crust breaks into pieces and
those pieces slide past each other and
that's what they're trying to show here
here's a chunk of the crust
here's another chunk of the crust and
there's this I've got Fault right
between them and they're sliding past
each other very slowly and so on the
surface what we notice is that maybe
every hundred years or so there's a
little jerk and there's an earthquake
but turns out way down deep it's moving
a little bit every day maybe a few
millimetres a little bit and that's
generating friction it's making heat and
cold water
in contact with that gets hot in the
fault zone rises to the surface and you
can get a hot spring up here near the
surface just because of this fault
movement so anywhere you have faults you
have the possibility of making hot water
in one of the most famous places in the
United States for this is Nevada so here
we're looking at a was this is called
the Basin and Range province all through
Nevada looks like this this chunk is
moving up this chunk is moving down
right between here there is a fault okay
and if you were to drill down in this
zone you might strike hot water so
here's kind of a cartoon diagram of what
I mean by this so this block is moving
down relatively this block is moving up
and friction is occurring along this
plane and if cold water is coming along
here then it might heat up and come up
you'll have hot springs up in here okay
that's the idea
so Nevada is in a geologic province
that's being stretched apart so the
crust is being is what are we being
pulled apart in breaking into chunks so
you can see from this view here that
it's a bunch of linear looking mountains
and valleys in between it's called the
Basin and Range well there's a fault at
the base on every one of those mountains
and here's a map of faults and the
colors tell you how fast the faults are
moving in millimeters per year point
being there's a lot of faults in in
Nevada that are they have the potential
of generating hot water so for example
here's what one looks like so there's a
fault nearby and there's this hot water
coming up making this hot spring out in
the middle of Nevada so they decided to
try to make a geothermal power plant
utilizing this hot water and so they
built this in the 80s and they started
to extract hot water out of the ground
and before they started that power plant
there was a geyser field out there in
the
Thatta bale Huawei geyser field so kind
of like Old Faithful just not as famous
and it would shoot off hot water and
there's hot springs around kind of like
I showed you in that last picture well
after they started the geothermal power
plant and they started extracting hot
water out of the ground one of the first
things that happened is that geysers
stopped and then the hot springs dried
up so here's a place that used to have
hot springs and there's nothing there
anymore and one of the problems you can
see in the background if you've never
been to Nevada it's super dry it's in
that rain rain shadow effect from the
west coast and it was just not that much
precipitation and so there's not much
replenishment of the groundwater so when
they started to extract the groundwater
out they just started to simply run out
of water so one of the things that they
did they realized early on is they have
to pump that water back into the ground
so the idea is they pump the hot water
out they run it through the steam
turbine generates electricity then they
take it after it's gone through the
turbine and they pump as much of it as
they can back into the ground so here's
a graph of that so this is time this is
where they started this y-axis is kind
of confusing this is just imagine how
much water is coming out of the ground
that's the red and how much water
they're putting back into them into the
ground that's the black so they start
out there getting a lot of hot water out
of the ground they're generating a lot
of electricity but as time goes on they
get less and less hot water out of the
ground and therefore they're collect
Rissa T their power output goes down and
down as well as well so they're still
generating a little electricity with it
but it's not nearly as much as they
thought they were going to get
unfortunately it's just too dry this is
the curse of geothermal resources in the
United States if you look at where most
of the geothermal resources should be in
other words if we were to drill in the
crust where would we expect to find hot
water you see it all over the West right
and the
Nevada right this whole region out here
that's kind of reddish and even a little
bit here are places where we would
expect to find heat sources under the
crust but it also corresponds to places
that are the driest in the country so we
talked about how this is at the driest
part in the country right through here
over here where it rains a lot not
really any geothermal resources so our
country has this problem that we've got
places that's generating heat but just
not enough groundwater to really take
advantage of it so New Mexico is one of
these places we have a lot of volcanoes
in New Mexico so in this map all the red
says volcanic rocks younger than 5
million years old in geologic time
that's considered a pretty young Rock 5
million years so if we have these so all
this red is relatively young volcanic
rocks that means there's probably still
magma under the crust and we also have a
lot of earthquakes in New Mexico this
cluster right here near Socorro is due
to what we call the Socorro magma body
there's a blob of magma down there
moving around and some of these clusters
that you see are actually due to fault
movement we have a lot of faults in New
Mexico and this is the map of them the
colors designate the different ages of
them but point is is we've got faults
that are moving that should generate
heat we've got magma that's also
generating heat we ought to have
geothermal resources but like the like
in Nevada we just don't have much
groundwater and so because of our lack
of groundwater and also we haven't
really found really hot water in New
Mexico yet here's a map of the state so
the blue says temperatures below 100
degrees centigrade so that's not hot
enough to boil so you're not going to
get steam out of it that's the blue and
then the red says temperatures above a
hundred so in theory that would be
enough to generate steam they've never
really got it a well that can produce
enough hot water to run out
a thermal power plant though but we have
used some of this warm water for other
reasons so we have greenhouses in New
Mexico that use geothermal hot water so
it's pumped out of the ground it's
already hot it heats buildings New
Mexico State campus heats some of their
buildings with warm water
there are tapia fish farms that use some
geothermal hot water as well too just as
a source of you know warm water so we're
not generating electricity with it in
this in the state but we are using some
geothermal resources best that we can
our final renewable resource that we're
going to learn about in this class is
that of hydroelectricity which is the
idea of forming a dam so damming up a
river making a reservoir behind the dam
and then forcing that water through the
bottom of the dam so that it turns a
turbine which turns a generator which
makes electricity so we kind of talked
about this before when we did our
project with rivers and dams and
reservoirs and all that and in the
southwest all of those big dams that we
talked about have hydroelectric power
plants at the bottom of them so we
looked at Hoover Dam so remember this is
Lake Mead we're near Las Vegas and the
water comes out down here and turns
turbines to generate electricity so the
water goes in at the bottom of these
towers there's an inlet and the water
goes to this big pipe that goes through
the dam so this is I don't know like 100
feet below the surface something like
that headed towards these big turbines
and the turbines themselves are they
don't look like the steam turbines in
this in this case they look like giant
boat propellers or something like that
but the water goes through and turns
this shaft which turns this big
generator which in itself has magnetic
fields in it that rotates and the this
is what one of the generators looks like
taken out of its housing so
these things are the magnets and this is
spinning around about sixty times a
second so inside of hoover dam looks
like this each one of these red round
things has a generator in it so spinning
inside of here are one of those rotors
that you saw in the previous diagram so
all said together it's making about
2,000 megawatts so 2,000 million watts
now to compare that with say some of our
coal-fired power plants in the u.s. so
we have coal-fired power plants of all
different sizes and of the biggest like
1500 to 2000 megawatts we've got 38 of
them and over 2000 megawatts we've got
29 of them so this number 2,080
megawatts is as big as one of our
biggest coal fire power plants here's
another example Grand Coulee Dam in
Washington State this is the Columbia
River that's being dammed up this is at
6,800 megawatts and again to compare it
it would is it would produce as much
electricity is about three of our
equivalent biggest coal fire power
plants another picture of Grand Coulee
Dam while they're going over the
spillway they're the world's largest
hydroelectric dams in China it's called
the Three Gorges Dam it took them a very
long time to build it it was very
controversial because they flooded
cities in the process to do this has 32
turbines makes twenty two thousand five
hundred million Watts megawatts about
ten of our largest coal fire power
plants and it's quite a feat of
engineering tremendous amount of water
goes through Three Gorges Dam you can
see it spans this really broad distance
here across well hydroelectric power is
great as long as you have water but a
lot of these dams that we're talking
about
once we have in the United States are on
the west coast and Southwest like like
Meade and Hoover Dam here and the
problem is we have been undergoing a lot
of drought and we have a lot of water
allocations like we talked about in the
past so one of the problems were having
is there is not enough water left in the
reservoirs to actually run the
generators to run those turbines
so here's Lake Mead here's a recent
photo and the water is so low that it's
actually not even going into the pipes
that lead to the generators you can see
so here we're on Lake Mead here that's
where the top of the lake
ought to be right yeah it's like a
bathtub ring you can see here very low
compared to word where it should be or
here's another example you can see where
the shoreline is supposed to be out in
here right and then the water is way
down here another example this is was
all underwater except for this little
island sticking up and you can see all
the land that's now sticking out of the
water because of the drought situation
this is a boat ramp boat boat ramp slash
boat launch area marina
and here's where it used to be right
this is where you used to launch your
boat off of this and you see it they've
had to move it all the way down there so
this is a problem in many of our
reservoirs that have hydroelectric dams
right now there's just not enough water
to run the generators here's one from
California this is what the dam looked
like maybe I don't know 10 20 years ago
and this is a more recent photo and you
can see those pipes right there those
are the turn stalks that's what takes
the water from the lake and takes it
down to the generators but they're high
and dry they're not getting any water to
generate electricity with so pros and
cons making water with hydroelectric
dams is great in terms of greenhouse
gases because they just don't generate
any they're just spinning around
generating electricity 24 hours a day
burning no fossil fuels no air pollution
is being produced
the cons back when we had our lecture
about the problem with dams and how that
changes the water temperature and the
water pH and and all that stuff that
still applies right blocks fish
migrations all those things all that
still apply so what we talked about
before applies here as well
you can't dam up a lot of rivers in most
of the country in fact you need the
right kind of topography and we really
only have that along kind of the west
part of the United States where we have
a mountainous terrain and then as I just
Illustrated these things are subject to
drought so as long as you have water and
you can run water through your turbines
then that's great but if we're in the
drought situation like we've been in the
last 20 ish years it's getting harder
and harder to actually generate
electricity with this method
you